Putin und seine atomstreitkräfte der
rosenpräsident schaut auf seine
bedrohlichsten Waffen und das ganze wird
übertragen im kremlfernsehen natürlich
diese Bilder die schickt Putin um die
Welt die sollen uns gerade Angst machen
mal wieder wie dicht steht Putin
tatsächlich davor eine Atomwaffe
einzusetzen er der seit einigen Tagen
das Gerücht streut die Ukraine selbst
wolle das eigene Gebiet mit einer
schmutzigen Bombe verwüsten
rot Mittwochnachmittag der
kreml-diktator höchstpersönlich ergreift
das Wort Wladimir Putin ätz zunächst
gegen die USA sie haben das ukrainische
Territorium in ein Übungsplatz für
Experimente der biologischen
Kriegsführung verwandelt jetzt Pumpen
sie schwere Waffen rein ohne einen
einzigen Beleg für seine These vorweisen
zu können erklärt Putin dann uns sind
die Pläne bekannt zu provokationszwecken
eine schmutzige Bombe einzusetzen das
heißt der Russen Anführer droht jetzt
höchstpersönlich eine Atombombe in der
Ukraine zu zünden und diesen gewaltigen
Terroranschlag anschließend Kiew in die
Schuhe zu schieben bemerkenswert ist
jedoch nicht nur die Tatsache dass Putin
die würde Theorie nun persönlich
verbreitet sondern auch Zeit und Ort an
dem er das tut denn Putin hält sein
atomrede während der Übung der
strategischen abschreckungskräfte der
russischen Armee sie halten am Boden zu
Wasser und in der Luft ein Training ab
um den Ernstfall zu proben einen
Atomangriff auf Russland bei dem
Russland mit einem Nuklearschlag
antwortet das Putin den Ukrainern jetzt
persönlich vorwirft eine schmutzige
Bombe zünden zu wollen stellt eine
weitere Eskalation der russischen
lügenkampagne dar
bei unserem Studio jetzt Bild
meinungschef Philipp pirtow herzlich
willkommen auch an Dich guten Morgen wie
dicht steht Putin tatsächlich vor dem
Einsatz einer Atomwaffe tja das ist
glaube ich die eine Milliarde Euro Frage
das weiß man natürlich nicht weil es
handelt sich hierbei zunächst mal um
erneute atomerpressung um eine
Desinformationskampagne wir erinnern uns
daran Putin hat immer wieder mit dem
Einsatz von Atomwaffen gedroht und dann
hat der Westen klar gemacht das wird die
russische Armee nicht überleben man wird
zumindest alle russischen Soldaten
Truppen Militärgerät die sich in lokalen
befinden zerstören auch China und in den
haben klargemacht die haben keine Lust
auf eine auf ein Einsatz von Atomwaffen
auch keine Lust auf atomdrohung Putin
hat das also zurückgefahren jetzt ist
die atomdrohung wieder da versteckt in
Form dieser Warnung dass die Ukraine an
einer schmutzigen Bombe Wasser zu
veröffentlichen die Russen eben diese
Fotos die wir gerade sehen hier Philipp
das sollen Fotos sein die den Bau einer
ukrainischen schmutzigen Bombe zeigen
veröffentlicht auf den Seiten des
russischen Staates ganz genau das was
wir hier sehen das hat das russische
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
das soll ein Beweis sein der die Ukraine
sozusagen ertappt der das entlarvt die
Pläne eines schmutzige Bombe zu bauen
das hat das russische
Verteidigungsministerium auf Social
Media verbreitet um auch die Welt von
ihrer Theorie zu überzeugen was sind das
für Fotos ja das sind mittlerweile 12
Jahre alte Fotos von slowenischen
Rauchmeldern die die slowenische
Atombehörde einmal aufgenommen haben
noch mal zeigen was was genau die
Rauchmelder sind vielleicht kennst Du
das einmal
Tüten oder richtig man sieht ein
Plastiksack man sieht darin die
Rauchmelder und man sieht das
schwarz-gelbe Zeichen auf dem drauf
steht es ist radioaktiv und warum steht
das da drauf weil der weil das von der
slowenischen Atombehörde einmal zu
demonstrationswecken bei irgendeiner
Präsentation vor zwölf Jahren
veröffentlicht wurde jetzt haben sie die
Fotos wiederentdeckt auf den Seiten des
russischen verteid Bildungsministerium
Copy und pays irgendwo aus dem Internet
zusammengeklappt das könnte Ukrainisch
aussehen was könnte unsere Geschichte
sinnvoll bildlich darstellen und dann
hat man das da eben drauf gestellt auf
die Seite genau ganz plumpe
putinpropaganda die kein Mensch mit mehr
als zwei Gehirnzellen glauben kann
leider scheint es für die russische
Bevölkerung gerade zu reichen wie
bewertest du diesen Move von Putin was
will er damit erreichen er will vor
allem Verunsicherung stiften sein großes
Ziel ist es glaube ich die Ukraine und
den Westen abzuschrecken also er will
dass wir aufhören die Ukraine zu
unterstützen da geht es gerade vor allem
um Restaurant die süd-ukrainische Stadt
die von Russland besetzt wird ganz genau
die Ukrainer stehen ganz kurz davor es
heißt dass die Russen dort überhaupt
keine Chance haben militärisch und um
das irgendwie aufzuhalten oder zumindest
um davon abzulenken hatte es diese
schmutzige Bombe ins Spiel gebracht ein
putinenmärchen und dazu Philipp piatov
unser Bild meinungschef danke vielen
Dank an dich
[Musik]